al salir el sol sobre este barrio de
quién la gente se despertó con las
secuelas de un ataque con drones los
trabajadores de la oficina de Correos
estaban ocupados reparando las ventanas
dañadas los vecinos de la central
eléctrica atacada dicen haber visto las
explosiones en plena noche
oí un avión no tripulado volando por
encima después una fuerte explosión
luego vi un Destello en mi ventana y
hubo una segunda explosión el cielo se
llenó de un espeso humo negro
los residentes locales están
conmocionados por lo que vieron Aunque
algunos sospechaban que se avecinaba un
ataque
Nadie puede acostumbrarse a eso es
invierno la gente no tiene luz ni
calefacción es gente corriente no nacies
como dicen los rusos
en este barrio como muchos otros de casi
todos los negocios están equipados con
un generador se han convertido en
imprescindibles para los comerciantes
acostumbrados ya los cortes de
Electricidad cotidianos
lo compramos hace un mes cuando
empezaron los bombardeos pasivos para
poder tener luz y unas condiciones de
trabajo decentes dentro de la tienda
Alexander vende accesorios telefónicos
pero ahora tiene que soportar el olor a
gasolina siempre que está en el trabajo
cuando se va la luz nadie sabe cuánto
tardará en volver
podemos evitar los cortes de luz
programados pero es más difícil cuando
hay un apagón repentino llevamos sin luz
desde las nueve de la mañana ya han
pasado cuatro horas
Alexander puede considerarse afortunado
al menos con un generador se mantendrá
caliente mientras que fuera las
temperaturas caen en picado por debajo
del punto de congelación